لكن كل ذلك لم يحل دون استمرار الايرانيين
في احتجاجاتهم عدد المعارضين للنظام
يتزايد خلال السنوات الاخيره وفق خبراء
ايرانيين يختصر الباحث في مؤسسه كانغي
للسلام الدولي كريم سجاد بور المشهد بقوله
لصحيفه فورين فارس لم يسبق ان بدا نظام
الايراني في سنواتها الثلاثه والاربعين او
43 اكثر ضعفا من اليوم لكن وخلافا للتحرك
الذي قاده الخميني للاطاحه بالشاه في
سبعينيات القرن الماضي لا يوجد قائد
للحركه الاحتجاجيه الحاليه هناك شخصيات
شخصيات من مناطق مختلفه يشكلون مصدر
الهامل للمحتاجين بين هذه الشخصيات الناشط
في الدفاع عن حريه التعبير حسين دوله
اطلق سراحه في نوفمبر بعد ما اضرب عن
الطعام شهرين والمعارض ماجد توكلي الذي لا
يزاده لا يزال قابعا في السجن والناشطه
المخضرم في الدفاع عن حقوق النساء فاطمه
الزهريه
[موسيقى]